All right. Welcome everybody. People are still coming in.
Thank you for staying up to the last day, to the last
sessions. And
my name is Teresa Davoli. I'm associate professor at NYU
Medical School, and I'm very happy to chair this session
on the latest findings in the aneuploidy field.
We will span the full arc of tumorigenesis from cancer
initiation to
how we could use aneuploidy as a way to predict
the tumor microenvironment and the patient's
response. We have great speakers, Sam Aparicio from
University of British Columbia in Vancouver, and Nick Navin and Andy
Anderson, you already heard from him as well, and
myself.
And so, before we start,
I just wanted to
advertise. I just wanted to mention a special AACR
conference that will be organized next year, early next year,
2027, in Vancouver.
And this special conference is really on the topic of
aneuploidy and chromosomally complex cancers.
So all of you should be quite interested in
joining this conference and please advertise it
with your colleagues as well. And it's organized by Sam Aparicio as
well as Sharon Kantor and Carlyn Chimprich.
So they're putting together an exciting set of speakers
for all of us.
And so
we just have a few more minutes,
but I think we can
start with the first talk that will be given by
Sam Aparicio.
Sam, as I said, is from University of British Columbia in Vancouver.
Thank you so much for joining us, Sam, and we look forward to your
talk.
Great. Thank you. And I'd like to begin by thanking AACR and
the organizers for the opportunity to talk about some of our
work,
in the origins of mutations, and I slightly liberally interpreted
the theme of the session as well to include a little bit on aging of breast
tissue.
So I'd like to present
two short stories. One about the origins
of founder gene dosage mutations in the breast, and
I think we're going to hear a lot more about that from Nick, from his seminal work.
And then some more recent work on the relationship between
chronological age and changes in cell composition in the breast.
Now, to introduce the topic, for those of you who don't
necessarily work on breast cancer or
mutational processes, I just want to remind us
that all forms of mutation of course can contribute
to cancer. But we've been studying for many years
a particular form of mutation, which involves
the types of topological
shuffling and gene dosage changes that can occur
in cancer tissues. Because
it turns out that
mutations that copy paste genes or delete genes or invert them are
quite common,
and span a spectrum from rather small
scale events all the way up to whole genome duplication where the entire
gene complement gets duplicated.
And these have a particular significance in cancer development because
unlike single nucleotide variants, which are very, very
prevalent,
a single mutational event can, in principle, disrupt genome
organization and can affect potentially the expression of hundreds of
genes,
through altered gene dosage and topological domains.
So they have a particular mechanistic significance.
And the impact of copy structural variant
mutation on transcription has now been very well
documented across many cancers. This is work taken
from the Pan-Cancer Working Group
papers that appeared a few years ago.
There have been many similar studies that have shown this, that the
mutational copy number burden is very variable between
cancers. Cancers such as breast and ovarian cancer tend to be
highly mutated in this way, whereas, for example, some
sarcomas, much less so. But when you look at the
effect size, transcription is the thing
which is most strongly affected,
over all mutation classes. And copy number changes are the biggest
single contributor to that. So they have some
mechanistic importance. Now,
it's now well over a decade ago, 15 years or so ago, we had started
trying to look at the genomes of established cancers,
established breast cancers. And we, together with TCGA and ICGC,
there were a number of international efforts to characterize
the genomes of cancers. And we arrived at the observation
that when you look over all breast cancers, if you were to examine
the genome and look at the copy number amplification and deletion map, this
plot in the center here shows the prevalence of chromosomal
alterations that either result in a gain of a chromosome or a loss of a
chromosome,
or chromosomal segments, that you can see that there's a particular chromosomally
restricted pattern in terms of prevalence.
And we now understand that these amplifications and deletions
are key for
mediating oncogene drivers and altering the function of tumor
suppressors. And, in fact, they
also co-segregate patient behavior.
So we know that these cancers with different alterations have different
biological behaviors shown
here in these survival curves.Now,
all of this analysis was conducted with bulk tissues.
We took tumors and literally put them in a blender and applied the
genomics of the day, which has been bulk genomics,
looking at the tissues. But this doesn't teach us so much
about where and when this gene dosage landscape might
emerge.
And so to look at that question,
a few years ago, we decided to
start studying the normal epithelium of the
breast to ask the question:
Do we observe gene dosage mutations, and if so, where do they
occur?
And to do this, we
chose to take an approach of single-cell genome sequencing.
This is something that we implemented a few years ago.
We were inspired by Nick's early work in developing single-cell
techniques for looking at genomes and transcriptomes.
And this method simply takes dissociated cells from whatever
tissue and allows you to do shallow
transposition, non-amplification-based reads
over the genome of lots of single genomes,
and then read them out and look at
copy number and structure. Now, to do this in the
breast, what we did was we took normal breast
tissue and flow sorted the epithelium
into the two major lineages that have been described.
So for those of you not familiar with the human breast,
broadly, there are two epithelial lineages referred to as luminal,
in which there are some subsets of cells that have been described.
These are the milk-producing cells.
And then there's a basal myoepithelium surrounded by a basement membrane.
The myoepithelium is the contractile layer.
And
we were particularly interested in this
set in patients who are
genetically wild-type, but also through a collaboration with Joan
Brugge and the Gray Project in Boston, in looking
at carriers of BRCA1 and BRCA2
germline alleles, which are susceptibility genes for breast
cancer. So we took these samples, flow sorted them,
and then looked at the constitution.
Now, the way that we're representing the mutational
impact, the first observation in these heat maps,
every line in this heat map represents a single genome,
and the gray colors imply that the cells are diploid, the normal
chromosomal state, whereas a yellow or orange color is a gain, and blue is a
loss. And you can see that there are a number of cells, these are four different
patients
among the BRCA and wild type, that contain
chromosomal gains and losses, which look to be chromosomally
restricted. And the first observation is, first of all, we could see
these, and particularly
gains in chromosome 1q, which is
part of the cancer landscape, as well as losses
in chromosome 10 and some other chromosomes.
And so we could see that there was a pattern, and it was restricted, but
also rather infrequent. So very few cells have these
aberrations. The vast majority of cells here, much less
than 1% of the cells seem to have
copy number gains.
The fact that we could see many cells with apparently the same gain
immediately posed another question, which is whether these are really clonal
amplifications or whether they might be occurring independently.
And it's quite hard to date these
phylogenetically with this process, but one thing you can do
is look at the alleles that are present
and phase them. And phasing the alleles would tend to
suggest that because we see roughly equal representation of both
A and B alleles in these cells, that it's probably
more compatible with these being sporadically recurrent events.
Although, it doesn't preclude that eventually you will get a clonal
amplification that leads to
canalization of one of these. But at least the initial observation
was that allelic phasing suggested these might be sporadic.
And
the other
observation is that we found mutations in the luminal
cells quite prevalent.
We did not find them so much in the basal cells, so it appears to
be lineage restricted. In other words, the copy
number aberrations seem to be just in the one cell type.
And that's important because there's been some debate, particularly amongst
different subtypes of breast cancers, to the exact origin
of the landscape.
There are breast cancers that have more of a basal
myoepithelial phenotype,
but in pure, normal basal epithelium, we didn't see so many
of these mutations. The other striking feature is
that
the pattern is partially reflective of the breast cancer landscape.
This plot reproduces, again, the TCGA
ICGC Metabricks copy number landscape.
And what you can see is that 1q is a very prevalent event in
established breast cancers, as is loss of 10, but clearly
established cancers have many more events.
Interestingly, we see losses in chromosome 7,
but we
did not see were gains in chromosome 8q, suggesting that
this is a very prominent amplification event in breast cancer,
but we didn't observe it,
suggesting it really is happening potentially
laterAnd the other observation here is
that we found this in tissues. We also looked in cultured
mammary epithelial cells, such as we had available at the time, and we've
since extended this to other studies where we've looked at organoids that
we've cultured from mammary epithelium.
We have quite a large bank of
cryopreserved normal mammary epithelium.
We do see some cells that contain the gains in 1q
and loss of 10, but much, much less prevalent.
This is frustrating because we'd like to study this
phenomenon functionally, but capturing this
in organoids, for us at least, seems to be quite hard.
And it raises the question of what's the real difference between cultured
organoids and breast tissues that might account for this,
and this we don't know.
The lineage bias extends to co-occurrence.
So we know that
with 1q
gain and loss of 10,
in some cases, these apparent losses are
actually due to fusion translocations which lead to a gain loss event, and that's
been described in a number of publications and we observed
this. And we also saw a degree of genotype
bias,
in that
there was more bias to these co-events in the
BRCA1 and BRCA2 heterozygous patients than there
was over wild type, although the differences were quite modest in
absolute terms.
Finally, the
question of aneuploidy itself.
We saw
very high aneuploidy that was cancer-like occurring
predominantly in the BRCA1/2 heterozygotes
and much less in the wild type epithelium.
And when you look at the ploidy and rank it in terms of its correlation
pattern with established breast cancers versus ploidy, you see a lot
of cells that can have high ploidy but actually have very little
correspondence to a cancer-like phenotype.
And it's these cells over here that were more in the BRCA1 and
BRCA2 carriers. And we think that this may represent
lesions that were microscopically invisible as precursor lesions but
were already, say, partially on their way to forming more
established cancers, although we need a better
histomorphological correlation to really address that.
So,
this was,
I think, one of the things I want to mention here that we were fortunate enough to
be able to publish this at the same time that Nick produced his study, and I
think we're going to hear about that in detail,
where there were similar findings.
We think that there is particular significance to the
chromosomal gains and losses. I also want to highlight for those of you who are
thinking about this field, that there have been a number of papers.
I'm highlighting a couple here from the Elledge Lab and the Shelza
lab that have actually looked functionally
at the roles of chromosome 1q using model systems.
And it seems clear that 1q gains in particular,
can confer selective advantage, some of which may be mediated
by Notch signaling. There are other things on 1q such as MDM genes which
may be related to p53 function. And I think that this
is actually a very fruitful area for further investigation because there's a clear
pointer to this being some kind of an important founder event, but the
actual fitness that's conveyed by it, I think is something
that needs looking into further.
Okay, for the second part, I'd just like to then address a
related question, which is that we see that there
are these lineage copy number mutations that occur in
normal tissues. We think they're probably age-related,
and that's been shown in other work.
And it raises the question of how does the actual composition and
function of the breast change with age?
And this is epidemiologically important.
Early work by Malcolm Pike, who looked into the epidemiology of breast
cancer incidence, clearly established that there's an
age-correlated incidence of breast cancer and also
raised the idea that, in terms of breast tissue
aging,
there's a sort of rate of aging change which happens over
the lifetime of an individual that's strongly
correlated with the onset of
menopause.
So the changes in post endocrine signaling that happen.
And more recent work looking at SNVs has established that there's
a strong age-correlated incidence
of SNVs, which we would expect,
to see if this age correlation is
real.
So to look at the age-related changes, we took advantage of
another collection of cancer-free individual breast
cancers which we had previously
constructed into a microarray. This comprised
537 patients with a range of ages.
We took advantage of some of the latest
single-cell spatial imaging methods, imaging mass cytometry, and
Xenium to look at transcripts.
And again, inspired by Nick's work on the Atlas,
defining cell types in the breast cancer, we wanted to ask how many of
these cell types can we find and how do they change?
How do their relationships change as a function of age?
And so to do this, we took the reduction mammoplasties and the cores.
We
identified something like over 3 million cells in the 1,700 tissue
cores,
imaged with IMC. We also classified
histomorphological changes of normal epithelium
in order to be able to classify cells in the stroma as well as
the epithelium,
and then used dimensional reduction and clustering to identify
cell types based both on the IMC,
and on the Xenium subset.The
main difference, there's a strong overlap between these two methods.
The main difference is that the transcriptional data sets give us a much richer
look at metabolic and other functional states of
cells compared, say, with the antibody set, which gives
us great resolution in terms of protein markers.
And so then we can ask, how does the spatial context of the
epithelium change as a function of age?
Now, to get at this, the other important element is to do some image
processing, both in terms of segmenting cells, but also
to identify macro structures. So we were interested
in the terminal ductal lobular unit structure of the
breast, which is a branching
morphological structure. We wanted to learn about the differences between
ductal regions and lobular regions.
And so we created tissue masks to segment this as well as segmenting the
cells and pull out these features.
So the overall findings here are that there's a general cellular
decline with age, perhaps not surprising, but most tissue
elements go down. There are just fewer cells,
and
particularly
epithelial cells. But then we can ask, are there
specific changes in relationships?
And when we look at the number of heterotypic interactions, so
between distinctive cell types and inflammatory
cells, what we see is that, yes, there are more
endothelial cells,
there are more inflammatory macrophages, more fibroblasts.
CD20 B cells seem to be reduced.
And we see that
these changes also occur with dendritic cells, not replaced here, but there seem to
be fewer dendritic cells as patients age.
And these changes
lead to
decreased cellularity within lobules, which is where the
majority of epithelial cells are
clustered, and somewhat increased in ductal cells.
A particular
interest is that stromal immune cell types show
quite a strong
change, both in density
and in their relationship
to the epithelium. And because we also have
had transcriptomics, we were able to look
into which were the most prevalent cell
functional state changes. And here,
what's of interest is that fibroblasts and adipocytes showed
by far the strongest transcriptional regulation as a function of age.
In the case of fibroblasts, a fairly strong decrease
in
genes that are associated with ECM assembly and remodeling.
They decrease as a function of age.
The only transcript that sort of reached any level of significance, interestingly,
was the leptin receptor. Leptin, as some of you will know, is
involved in the hormonal signaling axis that has to do with lipid
metabolism.
And in contrast, adipocytes showed a very strong
regulation. There were almost 90 genes that reached
fairly large levels of significance, indicating that adipocytes
were increasing in adipogenic factors and
increasing lipid processing. Whereas among
epithelium,
the strongest influence was a gene that's probably involved in
epithelial-mesenchymal communication.
And so it communicates the idea that there seems to be a
strong alteration,
particularly in stroma, particularly in adipogenic stroma and
fibroblasts, in conjunction with age-related declines
in
immune cell function.
As
you might expect, menopause, so when we stratified these
patients as a function of age,
the most variable features occur below the age of 50,
and over the age of 50, the number of variable features
is much diminished. So as has been well established,
host endocrine signaling dominates many of these
effects in the background.
And so we arrive at
the position where I think what we've seen in this preliminary study is
that this is sort of the summary of what we saw, is that there's a total
decrease in cellular elements, a decrease in some of the interactions
which are comprised with
decreases in cells that might be undertaking some
level of immune surveillance as well as reaction, and
alterations in inflammatory macrophages and adipocytes,
which suggests that as the breast ages, there's
increasing adipogenesis and inflammation.
And I think it remains to be established how all this will
feed into the surveillance of gene dosage mutations, but
something for the future.
So, I'd like to stop there, and I particularly want to
thank Vinci Au and Eric Li, who led within my lab
many of these studies, and acknowledge
my collaborators in Cambridge, Raza Ali and Pulkit Gupta,
who worked on the IMC study, and Joan Gray,
and a long-standing collaboration with Sarab, which we worked with on the
lineage epithelium, as well as our funders, the Gray Foundation,
BCRF, and BC Cancer. I'll stop there.
Thanks.
Thank you. Questions. If you have questions, please use the mic.
I see Nick.
Oh, okay. All right. I'll start.
Yeah, wonderful talk, Sam. I was wondering, in our normal
breast atlas as well, when we try to compare metadata for aging and menopause, it
was pretty hard to distinguish between the two of those.
I was wondering
if you could attribute some of these changes directly to
menopause versus... kind of aging-related differences.
And I guess you can look at the period before and after menopause maybe to get a
better idea.
Yeah. That's a great question.
I think there's two elements to this.
One is that menopause is actually a very difficult
state to define precisely, because it's a
physiological shift in host endocrine signaling that takes place over a number of
years.
And the clinical way that it's often done is people
do a questionnaire and they say yes or no, but that doesn't actually represent
the biological state. So typically,
sort of clinician-determined menopause is not such a great way of
doing. But here we do have age-continuous measurements,
and in some earlier work, we had shown that
there's a very strong age-correlated change in
transcription and gene expression for
some epigenetic drivers as well as ER drivers.
So if you look at ER signaling,
proteins like GATA3 related proteins and
FOXA1 and so on, you can see that they are sort of colinearly
correlated with age, which implies, I think, that those transcripts could
be hormonally responsive. And I think there's now data that
shows that EZH2 and its trimethyl mark, which we
earlier had showed has a very strong age correlation, are in fact ER
responsive genes. So I think you can tie some of these things to endocrine
signaling. But I completely take your point that quite
aside from that, one would like to sort of subtract that signal out
and look at the
remainder. And it's quite hard because the endocrine signal is
so strong in the background that I think it's tricky,
but I'm sure both contribute.
Thanks. Beautiful work.
More questions?
Yes, thanks. Wonderful talk. So I have, I think, more of a broad
question. Well, I think it will feed into a broad question is, what's your sense of
BRCA1 and BRCA2 in terms of their actual role with
the normal tissues in terms of heterozygotes and mutations?
I know you showed a slightly increased rate of copy number alterations or
these aneuploidies within the heterozygote carriers.
Is there any evidence that
in those heterozygotes that HR might be somehow involved?
Any evidence of seeing, if you look at the individual reads, evidence of
micromol immediate deletions, et cetera?
Or, I guess, what are your general thoughts on those processes?
Or is it maybe a more permissive environment when you have those heterozygotes, so
they facilitate these changes, but they're not mechanistically linked
to BRCA1, BRCA2?
Yeah. It's a great question, and I would say,
an unresolved one is the question of, is there
a BRCA heterozygous intermediate
phenotype, or is it more that by losing one allele, you're
creating
the sort of chances of losing two alleles is now greater, and it's really just that
you're biasing the forward chances that a cell gets a second hit?
We didn't see sort of read-based
HRD-like signatures as far as we could see.
The sequencing is quite shallow, so it also would be hard to resolve.
There probably are intermediate phenotypes that you can see because
in
methylation patterns, we think there's probably an intermediate methylation
state pattern, which
is yet to be really sort of fully pinned down.
And the other intermediate phenotype that has been described, but I don't think we
really saw it here, was in telomere erosion, because
telomere length is partly
dependent on homology directed repair.
And it seems like there might be an intermediate state there, where if you only
have half of the
key protein, that it will affect the rate at which
telomere repair can happen. We didn't see it in this study, but I think
it's quite possibly there.
Yeah. Sorry. Very quick because I'm very curious.
So that methylation phenotype, is that specifically at the BRCA1 promoter, or is
that a global phenotype?
No, I'm talking about global genome-wide methylation.
It seems to be a little different.
Don't know what the basis of that is. Yeah.
Great talk. I was wondering whether you have used the
spatial transcriptome to infer the aneuploidy as we
age as well, or-
The... Is the que-
... use things like InferCNV or similar-
Oh
... to try to infer to the aneuploidy as
aging progresses?
Yeah. That's a great question. We're trying to look at that.
It's quite hard. I think, inferring in
some... It's like formally, I think gene dosage is sort of formally
unidentifiable from the transcriptome because you can have different states would
explain
the same transcriptional states.
I think it's hard with InferCNV and related.
I think in tumors where there's a lot of aneuploidy, you can make some
correlations.
And I think the other thing to say is that the method that we used for looking at
the transcriptomes, which is a Xenium
array, it's great data, but it's quite shallow per cell.
So I think the only chance of doing that would be to make
very targeted, dense measurements.
And we were trying to do that, but I
actually think that, yeah,
actually what we're more trying to do now to measure this is to do,
it's sort of old school, but it's spatial CoFish with other
measurements, like antibody measurements that are multiplexed on top of the cells
so that we could really ascertain...
We'd like to know about the spatial location
of these aneuploidies because cell orientation might have
an influence, for example.
Great.
Not so much InferCNV. Yeah.
Yeah.
Thank you so much again.
Thanks.
So the next speaker, I'll introduce him from here because I have a mic.
The next speaker is Nick Navin from MD Anderson. Thank you.
Thank you so much for being here.
All right. Thank you, everyone.
You might have a little bit of deja vu here with the previous talk from Sam.
But yeah, we have some findings that are different and a lot that are the same.
So I think it's interesting to discuss these.
And I'll spend a good amount of time talking about future work and future
directions that we're taking as well.
These are my disclosures, not relevant to what I'm presenting today.
So this is work that we did, also looking at normal breast tissues and trying to
understand the role of aneuploid cells.
And, this work was done by a former graduate student, Yun Lin,
who graduated. She's a postdoc in Cornell in Dan Lindau's lab now.
Yuki Wang, who's just graduating now, and Kyler Wang, former postdoc who's a
faculty now in Shanghai. And then our collaborators at Baylor, Bora Lim
and Alistair Thompson.
And so, I don't need to spend a lot of time introducing the topic, but as we know,
most cells are diploid, and have 22 pairs of balanced chromosomes
plus the sex chromosomes.
Actually, quite a long time ago, in
one of the papers where I had
published one of the first single-cell DNA sequencing methods, although the focus
was mostly on the cancer cells, we also looked at normal matched tissues.
And, early on, we found that there were chromosome losses and gains
in some of the normal adjacent tissues.
And so at the time, we just called these pseudodiploid cells because they look like
they're diploid. And we didn't really know what cell types they were exactly.
We did some follow-up work on this. Again, it was the side of another paper.
A lot of this is not in the main results.
But, again, we found that these pseudodiploid cells were present even
in matched tissue, which was histopathologically
completely normal. And so we had a little bit better methods here so we could
quantify their frequencies a little bit better.
And I think we reported that they occur at a low percentage typically of
the cells that we profiled.
We actually talked a lot to Angelika Amon, who was really interested in these types
of cells. And, actually, in her lab, we worked with some of
her
postdocs to teach them the DOP-PCR single-cell method.
And,
actually, there was a lot of controversy in the field here early on because
single-cell DNA sequencing methods were a bit noisy.
And so there were some papers reporting that, for example, in the
brain, that 50% of the neurons have aneuploidy.
And she really wanted to do a systematic analysis of lots of tissues and get a
better idea of whether that was really true or not.
And she looked at both mouse and human samples and also reported
that you do have aneuploid cells in many tissue types, but that they occur at very
low frequencies, not the high
numbers that some people had reported.
And at the same time, of course, there's been this body of literature growing.
A lot of this work was done with Peter Campbell and the famous eyelid paper,
looking more at point mutations and finding that many drivers expand over
your lifetime. Actually, in our department, Systems Biology, we have a guy,
Ronghan Li, who just started a few years ago.
He did a body map paper comparing lots of different organ systems and showing both
mutations and even some copy number alterations in normal tissue types.
And there have been a bunch of papers on this now in the esophagus and
many type of normal tissues. And so,
this is a growing area. Actually, there's another session going on right now that's
entirely on this topic. So
the questions we were interested in really were, are there chromosome aberrations
that occur in epithelial cells from healthy women?
And do they result in losses and gains in genes that we care about for
breast cancer progression?
And Sam already ruined this for me a little bit, but I like to usually show this
slide and say, "Are these normal cells or cancer cells?" And
they have the chromosomal gains and losses that you see in many invasive breast
cancers, like the 1q gain, which has MDM4, AKT3, a bunch of other
genes.
Loss of chromosome 16q over here, which has CDH1.
That's very common in ER-positive breast cancer, and also, there's a mutation in
lobular cancers. And here's a loss of chromosome 10, for example, in another
cell.
So, in this study, we used the samples we had from the Normal Breast Atlas.
These are reduction mammoplasties from completely healthy women, no known diseases.
We also confirmed that by histopathology.
We did dissociate the tissue. This is fresh tissue.
It gets run back to the lab very quickly.
We did epithelial enrichment and then single-cell DNA sequencing and another
assay that we developed that does DNA and attack from the same cells, and I'll tell
you why that's important in just a minute.
At the same time, we made blocks for tissues, looked at H&E, and also
ran spatial transcriptomics, and then the very classical cytogenetic methods to
do DNA fish.
So this just shows you the data from a single patient.
In this patient, there are about 5% of the
epithelial cells were aneuploid. You can see most of them are blank.
That means they have balanced chromosomes, two copies of all the autosomes and sex
chromosomes. And then down here, you see some with the 1q gain, over here with the
16q loss. And these are just some examples of the cells.
But what's interesting is some of the genotypes, like this one over here, this was
quite expanded. So 59 of the cells had this genotype, and other ones were
more rare on other chromosomes.
Here's another woman. She was 45 years old.
Again, you can see most of the
cells are blank. That means they have two copies of the autosomes and sex
chromosomes. 4.85% of the aneuploid cells
had these genomic alterations, 1q gain.
This was chromosome 10q loss. And histopathologically, these look normal.
Actually, we excluded cases that had ADH or any of the kind of
premalignant lesions just because we wanted to look at very normal tissues here.
And again, we saw some of the genotypes expanding, like this one over here with 1q
gain, chromosome 10 loss. Over here, there are about 32 of these cells
and some other cells, but these were a bit rarer in this one.And so
across all the patients we looked at, 49 healthy women, about
83,000 cells, and these are kind of sorted.
So you can see that 1q gain is very, very common.
10q loss is also very common. 16q loss is very common.
We see other events. We'll talk about this one a little bit.
This is a chromosome 3 loss, and it's interesting.
As you can see, the breakpoints vary quite a lot here compared to some of the other
events.
We actually see this more in the basal cells.
And, yeah, there's various other events that occur, but many of them are kind of
patient specific or quite rare across the patients.
Another common event is loss of X chromosome.
We see that as well as gains sometimes,
which are illustrated down here in the epithelial cells.
So we had lots of metadata because this was the Breast Atlas project.
We collected many different variables.
But the only ones that were significantly correlated with the frequency of
aneuploid events as well as the CNA events was age.
And so,
Sam talked a lot about this, but this was significantly correlated.
As you increase in age, you get more of these aneuploid cells, and you also see
more copy number events.
If you split it into the expanded versus sporadic, there's also an interesting
pattern where the ones that were more sporadic and not expanded really don't
correlate with age, whereas the expanded ones have this
relationship.
And yes, we also compared this to TCGA data,
and saw that many of the events that we see in the normal breast across many
patients combined here, this is a frequency plot.
Things like 1q gain is common both in ER-positive and ER-negative disease.
Chromosome 10 loss, that's much more common in ER negative.
FHIT loss over here is common also in ER negative.
On chromosome 16q, the CDH1 loss, you see that more in ER positive.
The NF2 loss, that's more also in the ER-positive disease.
So next we use another method. This is a DNA and ATAC co-assay method.
So in the same cell, you can measure both the DNA alterations and the chromatin
accessibility. This is a method very similar to what Sam
presented using the nanowells, except we do two rounds of tagmentation.
So the first round of tagmentation, the chromatin's intact, and we introduce one
barcode. And so this is giving us
the open chromatin areas of the genome.
It gets dispensed into the nanowells.
We have a dual indexing system. And then after that, we completely remove
and lyse the chromatin, and we do another round of tagmentation, this time with a
different barcode. And so, using these two sets of barcodes, we
can determine then which areas have chromatin accessibility and which do not.
And there's also these chimeric molecules which are interesting to look at, and
this paper is on bioRxiv.
So, we use that then to look at the three
epithelial cell types that we see.
There's the luminal ones, which I split here further into luminal hormone
responsive and luminal secretory, sometimes called luminal progenitor.
And then the basal cells are over here.
In the attack data, if you combine all the cells, they separate into very three
distinct clusters representing those lineages.
And if you look at the aneuploid events, they occur in all the lineages, but
they're much more common in the two luminal lineages.
You can see they're much more sparse over here.
Other events, though, like the X chromosome loss, that happens in all the
lineages at a similar frequency. Actually, the X loss events, we see that in many
cell types, not just epithelial cells, which is very different from the epithelial
biology.
So then when we tie this data together, so we look at these copy number
aberrations and expansions. In some patients, you can see the majority come from a
single lineage, like this is from luminal secretory.
In other patients, you can see that these are all coming from luminal hormone
responsive over here.
But in many other patients, we see different copy number profiles, and they are
associated with different lineages.
So for example, over here, this loss on chromosome 22, this was
occurring mostly in the luminal HR lineage.
And if you look at this event over here with 1q, there's a few other copy number
events. This is happening mostly in luminal secretory lineage.
So these lineages really have different genotypes and different copy number
aberrations. Here's another patient.
Similarly, different genotypes in the lum HR lineage versus the luminal secretory
lineage.
And so this summarizes this across all the patients.
And you can see in many patients, the copy number aneuploid cells
are happening in both lineages. Sometimes it's more in one lineage than the
other.
And the basal cells, there are a few patients that have copy number
aberrations.
And so I'll show which ones they are in just a minute, but they're pretty
rare.
So then we could just take all the genotypes that came from the luminal lineage
versus all the genotypes that came from the basal lineage and then compare those
against the TCGA data. And we found that overall, the luminal hormone
responsive cells match much better to ER positive breast cancers, where you see
the 1q gain, you see more of the CDH1 loss on chromosome
16 than NP2 loss. And then on the other side, the luminal secretory cells,
you see more things like the PTEN loss, which is more common in the ER-negative
breast cancers, as well as some of the other events.
Suggesting possibly that these different lineages may be more likely to
give rise to ER positive versus ER negative breast cancer.
Now, the basal cells were actually also interesting.
Like Sam said, there were very few copy number aberrations in these
cells at all.
However, there was one interesting one, which was on chromosome 3 here, where we
see this focal loss. And I showed you earlier, the breakpoints varied a lot.
And this is the FHIT tumor suppressor, which is quite interesting.
It's not really something people study a lot for initiation
of ER-negative breast cancers,
but it may suggest that maybe sometimes these cells give rise to ER negative.
Of course, a lot more work needs to be done in this area, I think, to really figure
out this kind of, this causal relationship.
Because we have ATAC data, we can also look at specific genes and try to
understand, within these chromosomal gains and losses, which genes may be
important.
So for the luminal HR cells, we saw that there was differences in
chromatin accessibility for MDM4, which is a p53 regulator,
CDH1, E-cadherin, and NF2. And then on the luminal
secretory side, we saw chromatin accessibility differences for MCL1,
also for MDM4, and then also for PTEN over on chromosome
10.And then so spatially, we
also did spatial transcriptomics experiments. There was just a question about this.
So in our study, we inferred copy number from the spots in spatial
transcriptomics, and we mapped the aneuploid cells with
this patient had chromosome 1q gain, chromosome 10 loss.
And you can see they're mapping over here to this specific area, which includes a
lot of ducts and TDLUs. Interestingly, morphologically,
there's really nothing that you can see here.
We had several pathologists look at this, and morphologically, they look very
normal. But of course, they've expanded quite a bit here in the ducts, and we
confirmed that also by cytogenetics by FISH.
This is another patient, again, showing you some of those aneuploid cells.
There's the 1q gain that we can see in some of the spots in the tissue.
This one was a little bit more spread out, so not just in one area, but you see it
in several ductal areas. And this is a lobular area.
Again, morphologically, we really don't see anything abnormal here.
There's no hyperplasias, UDH, or anything like that.
So we think that it's interesting.
It's suggesting that at least visibly, we don't see differences here in the
tissue.
So to summarize this part,
what's interesting is that really almost every woman we looked at had
aneuploid cells, even the very young women that were in their
20s or in their 30s. And when we came up with the number that we
estimated, our average was about 3.91%, which was very
close to Sam's study, which was about, I think it was 3.25% or something.
I have it in the next slide.
Age was the only factor that we found that seemed to really correlate with
increases of these cells that are accumulating over the lifetime, also the
increases in the copy number burden overall.
And
many of the cells do clonally expand in the tissues and have events that we
typically associate with invasive breast cancers.
And they're mainly in the two luminal lineages, but as I showed you, there are some
events like the chromosome 3 F hit loss that we see in the basal
lineage. And spatially, they often cluster together, but
sometimes you can see they're a little bit more spread out in the tissues as well.
Of course, a tissue is just a 2D section, so it could be a
ductal lobule that's kind of running through it, and we don't really know how
that's connected exactly in the z-axis.
So yes, Sam presented his work, and I think it was
amazing how consistent some of the results were between our two studies.
And he came up with, I think they reported 3.25%.
So ours is 3.18. So very close. And in
a different kind of cohort of patients, also geographically a bit different.
They also, of course, looked at the BRCA 1/2 germline carriers, which we didn't
really look at too much.
And yeah, it was a beautiful study, and we worked together to kind of publish
this at the same timeline, which I think helped give a bigger impact as
well.
Yeah, we were just discussing this.
Around the time the papers came out, there was a lot of buzz and a lot of news
around this, and
it certainly has some implications for early detection and also
thinking about cancer risk.
Both papers were highlighted quite a lot in the media.
And so in my last few minutes, I'm just going to talk about some of the future
areas that we're thinking about here, the really interesting questions I think to
pursue here in the future.
I think the big one that we think about a lot is really,
can these cells, either the number of copy number events, the specific events, or
the frequency of these, be used in some way to predict breast cancer risk?
Breast cancer has a number of risk factors that are being shown here.
Alcohol,
age, of course, pregnancy.
And
what's interesting, of course, is some women had much higher frequencies of
aneuploid cells. Now, in our own data, we wouldn't know for a very long time
whether those women would ever develop breast cancer.
But I think it is an interesting question to think about whether we can quantify
that in some way. But this is actually a very hard type of study to do
because you need lifetime follow-up for these women.
And the majority of women, of course, don't develop breast cancer.
It's about one in eight or so.
But it's really, I think, fun and interesting to think about.
I think the BRCA 1/2 germline carriers in the paper that
Sam published, they looked at it. I think the number of patients was still kind of
small, and there was interesting data correlating it.
But I think it would be great to do a larger study on this.
Maybe you're already doing some of that work.
But this
could potentially help, I think, the BRCA carriers with decisions
about... A lot of them get double mastectomies and so forth.
So making decisions about
what to do in terms of reducing their own risk.
The other important thing to think about, I think here, is really the other driver
mutations, so P53 and PIK3CA. P53 is the most common
in ER-negative disease. PIK3CA is the most common in ER positive.
And so we'd like to know when these mutations occur relative to the
aneuploidies.
In
these studies, it's possible that they're acquired earlier on, and maybe they're
required to tolerate some of the aneuploidies like P53.
But it's also possible that they occur later on, and they're really more
responsible for these transformations to a malignant state.
So I think understanding that is very important.
We're also quite interested in mapping these a bit more to the cell states we
reported on in the Human Breast Atlas.
So we had about three major luminal hormone responsive cell
states and about seven luminal secretory ones.
And so being able to understand in a bit more detail.
The attack data is really just not that great for this because RNA data gives you
much more granularity on these cell states.
So it was hard for us to do from the existing data we have.
But I think looking at DNA and RNA together, you can start to get at these
questions a little bit more.
And then I think spatially understanding really what's happening in the tumor
microenvironment. When these cells get aneuploidy, morphologically, they don't look
any different, but are they interacting in a different way with their
stroma or their immune system? I think there's a lot of interesting questions
that could be investigated here. Do they change the vasculature as
well?And then finally, a lot of people have approached us
as well about looking at this in other organ systems, and I think it'd be very
interesting to look in prostate cancer and kidney, pancreatic, other
normal tissues. The challenge, of course, is collecting normal
tissues. The breast is a very accessible organ, which has made it a lot
easier, and there's a lot of cosmetic reductions.
Unfortunately, that's not the case for the pancreas and the kidneys and the guts.
And so we'd probably have to rely on postmortem tissues, which is a bit
more challenging to work with because usually DNA is degraded, RNA is also
degraded.
But yeah, I think there's opportunities to do similar work, and
there's been quite a lot of this done, I would say, on mutations across these organ
systems, but not as much on aneuploidy, especially using single-cell methods.
So I think that's another important future direction.
And then this is really the big question, I think, is trying to understand when
does cancer really occur?
You start with this normal epithelial cells.
I think we've established through this work, both of our studies, that these events
are happening very early on in normal tissues, and almost every woman seems to have
these, even at a young age, just in a small number of cells.
So what is the switch? What is this trigger?
When do these mutations occur, and when do other events occur?
Because we talked a lot about these events, but actually later on, there's other
events like chromosome AQ, MYC gain, and things like that.
And so they could be important for transitioning more to these early
pathological states, even ADH or DCIS.
And so I think there's a lot of work to be done in this area, too.
So that's where I'll end my talk. I wanted to just thank the people that contribute
a lot to this work,
Ian Lin especially, Shan Shan,
Chris Wang, Jia Hong, Kyler, Emmy, and others.
Our wonderful clinical collaborators that helped us a lot with getting these
tissues from all the plastic surgeons around our area,
and
The Human Breast Atlas and our funding support. So I'll take a few questions.
Thank you very much.
Hi, great work. I was wondering if you could comment a little bit more on the ATAC
data and whether you see any interesting patterns, any
correlations with aneuploidy, any sort of pre-malignant
epigenomic states, anything like that.
Yeah.
We probably could have done a lot more with the ATAC data.
The ATAC data was mainly used to just look at differential accessible peaks
for genes to try to figure out within these chromosomal events,
which genes might be important. And so, of course, there are thousands of genes, so
we try to look at ones that were a little bit more breast cancer-related, and those
were the ones that I presented on.
The ATAC data itself is a bit difficult, we found also in the Human Breast Atlas,
to correlate these cell states that we
see that
we find quite well at the RNA level.
So that was a bit more difficult, I think, for us to do with this
data.
Yeah, there's obviously a lot more I think we could have done with the ATAC data.
We can look a lot more at regulators and transcription factors and
the more typical stuff you would do with it.
For us, it was mainly a way to identify which cell lineage the copy number events
were occurring in. But yes, all that data is available if you're interested in
looking at it more.
We're happy to share it with you.
Hey, Nick.
Hi, Devon.
I
think your last slide summarizes the quintessential question.
I was thinking about the entire time you were presenting, if I could think of a way
to answer the final question. I was just curious if you guys have some
ideas how you might get at that question of where in the
trajectory do you actually become
a transformed cell. I
was just wondering what you guys were thinking, if you're thinking about functional
assays or some sort of taking inspiration from some of the talks
yesterday, like these AI-inferred
transcriptome. You know what I mean?
That people are talking about doing now with histology or,
yeah.
Yeah. I think in the human tissues, it's a little bit difficult.
We can probably figure out the timing of the mutations.
But
there's a lot of
abnormal pathologies that we can look at, but most of those
never develop into breast cancer.
So I'm not sure if that's the right thing to compare to.
And
interestingly, by the time you're DCIS, you have all the genetic alterations
you see in invasive cancers, and so that's already quite far
along. So something in between would be ideal.
No, I think in vitro work,
organoids, some of the stuff Sam was mentioning, if you have
cells that you can track and understand when these events are
occurring.
Yeah, no, I think a system like that would have much more temporal
dynamic information and would probably be a lot more informative, so.
Maybe if you just happen to catch the right person, right?
And you can actually see a clonal expansion with progressive
mutations, you'd be in the-- I don't know.
Yeah. Or if they do
transform in culture over time, that's another way to look at things, so yeah.
Great talk. I was wondering if,
do you have any hypothesis of why the luminal cells would be more
likely to show these aneuploidies compared to the basal, more proliferation,
more-
Yeah, I think the main thing that we saw in the Human Breast Atlas
was that when we looked for proliferating cells,
they were mainly in the luminal components.
So we saw a lot more proliferating cells for the luminal secretory.
We also saw a little bit of cells for luminal HR.
So, that's our main clue, I think, is that.
But of course, I did show you that the basal cells can also acquire
copy number aberrations. Those are much more focal.
Those are not supernumerary chromosome changes.
And so, it could be a very different mechanism, too.
And then finally, do you see or can you look at,
with this method set, copy number neutral loss of
heterozygosity at the level of arm level
orOf cytobands or focal levels.
Yeah. And we looked at that a lot, too.
I didn't present it in the work today, but
I think similar to data that Sam was also showing, that what's very interesting
is you do see that both maternal and paternal alleles can
arise, and are often kind of coexisting within the
tissue, so suggesting that there's more of a selection or convergent evolution that
occurs, and not always such a clonal origin like you typically see in
the more advanced cancers.
Yeah. No, but I meant in the non-aneuploid cells, in the diploid cells.
Yeah.
You see any copy number neutral LOH that stands out?
Oh, just copy number neutral. Yeah. So we didn't see a lot of it, no.
We looked specifically for that. A lot of reviewer questions for that, too.
But no, we mainly saw that different alleles that arose,
especially 1q, could come from both the maternal and paternal alleles.
But yeah, we didn't see a lot of copy neutral LOH.
Which, in other, I think, cancers, people have argued
might happen more frequently in the early stages, but at least in this
data, we didn't see that.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Nick, it's very elegant work, and I think it's
really pushed the field forward.
We struggle with, I think, probably what you struggle with, which is the
event rates here are so low that trying to study any of the
function here is tricky. But I was thinking about what you were saying
about future directions, that
maybe there's
a need to study higher risk groups, so where there are
known co-factors like smoking or alcohol
consumption. And then, there are sort of other genetic
epidemiology-type risk factors that might bias
our chances of seeing something. And I was thinking about this in
connection with the
CRUK mutograph studies-
Yeah
... Mike has been doing, because it strikes me that they're looking very
much at single-base signatures of mutagens, but then they've got all these mutagens
that they can't see signatures in.
Yeah.
I'm left wondering whether
there may be mutagenic signals, some of them environmental, that
actually express themselves in copy number space rather than in
single-base space, and how would we even approach that?
I was thinking the same thing when I saw Alexandrov's talk on the
early-onset colorectal cancers from the mutographs a few days ago. So yeah.
I
agree. Those are the challenges, right? They're occurring at low rates.
So we can probably address that with higher throughput methods.
I think there's a lot of
technology development being done in the area, and we can get there pretty quickly,
I hope.
But, yeah, I think it would be interesting to--
unlike the mutations where I think a lot of the etiologies have been kind of
linked, at least some of them,
that's far less the case with copy number aberrations.
And certainly, you're doing some work in that area, and there have been some
efforts to have copy number signatures, which I think can give
you a little bit of sense of just kind of what we already know, I would say, about
whether it looks like it's missegregation or non-homologous end joining, things
like that.
But
yeah, no, if you had high-risk groups, maybe you could learn more about
that, right?
I think that would be a good way to compare patients and get more signal
overall. Yeah.
Very interesting work. I was just wondering if you or other groups have
looked at whether aneuploidy increases in people that have
been pregnant before? Just because,
during pregnancy, you see an influx in whole genome doubling events in
memory cells. So I was wondering, assuming that not all the tetraploid
cells
are
gotten rid of during involution, whether those whole genome doubled cells might
produce some aneuploidy.
Yeah. So we didn't have actively lactating
women included here, and also not in our breast atlas.
We did have parity status for all the women, though.
And so that was not associated with a higher number of aneuploid cells.
So at least,
past, I think, lactation and pregnancy stages, we're not seeing
increases in aneuploid cells. Age was really the only thing that correlated with
the number of aneuploid cells.
Okay, great. Thank you.
All right. Great. Thank you everybody for sticking around.
We are perfectly on time. None of us will miss our flights back.
So,
again, Teresa Davoli here from NYU.
And so today we'll tell you a story about how we could utilize
copy number alterations and aneuploidies pattern as predictors of
immune evasion and also of therapy response.
So, as
we mentioned several times, aneuploidies, as defined as the gain or
loss of
human chromosome or chromosome arms, is extremely prevalent in human tumors.
On average, in any given human tumors, there are about
five chromosomal gains and six chromosomal losses.
And this is very prevalent across all range of solid tumors,
perhaps with the exception of hematological cancers, which have a lower level of
overall aneuploidy.
Aneuploidy is not only very prevalent in terms of numbers, but
it's also very specific in terms of the identity of the chromosomes that are gained
or lost. So there are patterns of aneuploidy that are frequently
seen in tumors. And so we can say that aneuploidy is chromosome-specific,
so not all chromosome are gained and lost at the same frequency, but there are
specific ones that tend to be frequent.
And again, this was mentioned already, but examples here that I will mention
also later in the talk are 9p loss, which is frequently lost, not in breast
cancer, in other tumors.
1q gain, as was also mentioned here several times.
It's a frequently gained event. Chromosome 7
gain, 8q gain, and others. In addition
of being chromosome-specific, cancer aneuploidy is also
tissue-specific. So there are patterns.
So the patterns of chromosome-specific aneuploidy that are seen in
cancer are often specific to the tumor types that we look at.
And so, as you can see, every tumor type has its own
fingerprint or signature of patterns of aneuploidy seen.
Of course, some of them are frequent across tumors.
For example, chromosome seven is the most gained chromosome across all
solid tumors, not hematological cancer, where it is actually lost.
But overall, we can find tissue specificity in the patterns of
aneuploidy.Why do we care about
aneuploidy? Not only because it could be actually one of the early initiating
events, but also predicts a patient outcome.
These are just some examples
of
studies that show how specific copy number alterations
are associated with patient progression or survival.
For example, 9p loss predicts progression from
premalignant oral pre-cancer to cancer.
18q loss predicts poorer survival in the context of colorectal cancer,
and 1q gain also predicts poorer survival in the context of
endometrial cancer.
So the entire field of aneuploidy, one of the main
questions that as a field we are trying to ask
is whether and how specific chromosomal aneuploidies are
associated with certain cancer hallmarks that are really
prevalent across tumors. And
there's been a lot of work by several labs in the
field, including some of them mentioned here, that have really contributed to try
to answer this question.
Today, I will mainly mention the
genetic interaction between copy number alterations and markers of
immunoevasion. As you all know, and as we heard
in many sessions in this meeting, during tumor progressions,
at different phases of tumor progression, from cancer initiations
to expansion to metastasis, the tumor microenvironment
generally transitions from an immune hot state to an immune cold state.
The immune hot state is characterized by a high level of CD8 T cells, a
high level of cytotoxic markers, a high level of interferon gamma
signature antigen presentation, while the immune cold microenvironment is
characterized by a lower density of CD8 T cells, a lower
response to interferon gamma antigen presentation, and also
markers of active immune suppression.
So years ago, work by our lab, Alison
Taylors, Matt Myers, and others, showed that the overall level of aneuploidy tends
to be associated with a decreased level of cytotoxic markers in the tumor
microenvironment. In this study, we defined an immune score that is based on the
average expression of cytotoxic markers, genes that are
expressed only in cytotoxic immune cells, including NK cells, so CD8
cells. And so if you look at across tumors, and especially in some tumor
types such as head and neck, melanoma, lung, and others,
the patients showing a high level of aneuploidy tend to have a decreased level
of the cytotoxic immune score.
But this is just the overall level of aneuploidy.
And so we really wanted to ask, which are the specific copy number
alterations that are associated with immunoevasion?
Can we use them as a biomarker of response?
And then ultimately, in the future, can we also potentially find
targets to specifically
hit those? And so, I will now
summarize here some of the work from my lab and others on an emerging
aneuploidy that has been associated in several studies with immunoevasion,
work by several universities, including MD Anderson, and several
others,
where really 9p loss is emerging as a strong
predictor of immunoevasion across several tumor types, not
all. And so this is just an example of the
studies. Here we focus on
HPV negative head and neck oral
cancer. And so, similarly to in the previous slide, here
we are using the cytotoxic immune score as a marker of
the extent of cytotoxic cells in the tumor microenvironment.
And so here what we did was a regression analysis between
the copy number alterations across the genome, in red are
gains, and in blue are losses, and the cytotoxic immune score.
Important here, we took into account the overall
aneuploidy score, the overall level of chromosomal instability as a covariate,
because that's been shown to independently associate with features in the
microenvironment. And so,
the bottom line of this plot is that you
clearly see it in this landscape, there's one event that stands out, which is 9p
loss. And so in this y-axis, we show the association with
immune score. So a
negative value indicates an association with immune cold, and a
positive value indicates an association with immune hot.
And so 9p loss stands out as one of the major event in head and neck
cancer to be associated with an immune cold tumor
microenvironment, so a decrease in the cytotoxic immune score.
In addition of being associated with immunoevasion, we also ask
whether aneuploidy, whether specifically 9p loss, was also predictive of
patient outcome, of clinical response.
And here we're very fortunate to collaborate with Caris Therapeutics that has
gathered
a huge data set of real-world data that we could mine.
And so what we saw is that in oral cancer patients, again, HPV negative,
9p loss was predictive of poorer survival in patients treated with
immune checkpoint inhibitors, but not in patients that were treated with other
therapies.
And so these findings was also clear validated, and Caris does offer
now the 9p assessment also as a way to potentially inform
clinical decisions.
In the last several years, there were several studies that
confirmed and also extended this finding, not only in the context of oral cancer,
but in the context of many other tumors, including mostly melanoma,
lung, non-small cell lung cancer, bladder cancer.
Yes, these are the main ones. Not breast cancer and not other tumors.
So there is definitely a tissue specificity that we need to
pay attention to.So one of the main
question that our lab and others are trying to answer is:
Which are the regions, which are the genes on chromosome 9p that drive immune
evasion? I won't be able to tell you the full answer to this question today.
This is
very much work in progress, but I just wanted to share with you some exciting data
that are ongoing in the lab. And so we build a computational
prediction model based on gene expression, copy number alteration, and also
single-cell data to try to understand what are the main
cytoband where immune evasion drivers are located,
specifically focusing on 9p. And there were three main regions on 9p that
stood out, which were 9p24, 9p21, and
9p13. And so what we are doing in the lab
is to create very controlled isogenic models
of these deletions. So we are taking cells, in this case, human oral
cancer cells, that do not have 9p loss, and we are
engineering the deletion of specific regions on 9p.
These are very large regions, 15 megabases regions.
It took several years in order to set up this protocol, but now it's
working quite well. And this is just an example of a successful
deletion of the generation of isogenic clones.
This is human oral cancer cells that,
as you can see here, do not contain 9p loss, but
after the genome engineering, we are able to see that
there's indeed efficient deletion of these large regions on 9p,
both by fish and also by whole genome sequencing.
Again, I won't be able to tell you the entire set of
experiments that we did, but I'm just going to focus on one vignette
on which we are focusing right now.
So the 9p13 caught our eyes because it's a
regions where there are a lot of
genes related to antigen processing presentation.
And so one of the thing that we did in collaboration with Mark Ymarkovic
is to perform a T cell killing assay with these cells.
So here we have isogenic cells that do or do not have the
9p13 deletion, only that regions, which is a large region of
15 megabases, so several genes are there.
These are heterozygous regions. So,
in this killing assay, we are pulsing the cells with a peptide,
Fox2B peptide. And then we are
co-culturing these cancer cells with a peptide together with the
CAR T cells from the Ymarkovic lab, either targeting with a
specific TCR, targeting MHC plus the peptide, or
non-targeting as a control. And so as you can see, in the non-targeting,
there is no significant difference in the proliferation between the wild
type and the deleted clones. If anything, the deleted seems to grow
slightly slower. However, in
the presence of CAR T cells that are targeting
specifically this peptide, with whom we pulse the
cells, what we see is that the deleted clones show a
significant increase in resistance to killing by these
T cells. This experiment was reproduced and
performed in several independent clones that were independently
generated from the cell lines, and was also validating
using other methods such as PI staining and apoptotic staining.
So in conclusion for this first part,
we can say the 9p loss is associated with immune evasion and poor
immune checkpoint inhibitor response across different tumor types, with the
strongest effect really seen in squamous tumors.
So also from the various published papers,
this strongest effect is seen in head and neck squamous, lung
squamous, bladder squamous,
with some effect also in the adenocarcinoma tumors, but not
as strong as in squamous. So there is probably something about the origin,
the type, the histological type of tumors.
So we next
expanded our analysis to different tumor
types. This is a pan-cancer analysis where we utilized a variety of data set,
including the TCGA, but also CPTAC and single-cell RNA sequencing
data.
And so here we
use a similar method as before. So we regress the
cytotoxic immune score against the copy number of
different regions across the genome, either at the arm level or at the focal level,
again, taking into account as a covariate the aneuploidy score, so the
overall chromosomal instability score,
which could be an important confounder.
And so these are just two vignettes.
One is for pancreatic cancer here, similar plot to what I showed you before for the
head and neck. So a lower value, a negative value indicates associated with immune
cold. A positive value is associated with immune hot.
And so as you can see here, 9p and 9q also loss
has a pretty strong association with immune cold microenvironment.
But we do see also other events, including, for example, 6q loss,
and importantly, which was mentioned before, this was not prepared,
1q gain. This is lung adenocarcinoma.
Again, we do see 9p loss.
In our data set, 9p loss in this analysis is not the strongest, but it's
been shown by several groups, including groups at Dana-Farber, to be a strong
predictor of immune evasion, immune checkpoint inhibitors.
Anyway, there is a signal for 9p loss, but again, a signal as well, an even
stronger signal for 1q gain. So
zooming out across all tumor types,
here we have the events that either at the arm level or at the focal level
are associated with immune cold microenvironment.
Again, the gain in red and the loss is in blue.
And so,
again, our favorite, our friend 9p loss is here is found across
different tumor types, including head and neck, bladder, lung,
and pancreatic cancer, as well as at the focal
level.
But the second most frequent event associated with immune cold
microenvironment is this 1q gain,
which we see especially in endometrial cancer.
We see it in lung adenocarcinoma. We see in pancreatic
adenocarcinoma and in skin
melanoma.One
notable exception actually to all these analysis is the kidney.
Kidney is always the exception to that rule.
You can
see here where 1q gain is actually associated with a lower,
and the same happens in other
analysis. So for some reason, kidney cancer
often behave in the opposite way and has been also
noticed by others as well.
So we
next
perform a deconvolution analysis of
the
bulk transcriptome
with different methods, we use five different methods,
the abundance of CD8 T-cells, B-cells, macrophages, and other cells,
and again, perform the similar correlations.
And so,
these are just some representative plot, and what you can see is that
9p loss has significant associations with a decreased level
of several of the adaptive immune cells, including CD8 T-cells and
B-cells in several tumor types. However, for
1q gain,
the strongest associations, it's with a decreased
abundance, not of the adaptive immune cells, but of the innate immune cells,
specifically macrophages and type one or
anti-tumor, or better called anti-tumor macrophages.
As you can see here, that are scoring in endometrial cancer, breast cancer,
lung cancer, stomach, and others.
And so overall from this immune deconvolution analysis,
we hypothesize that 9p perhaps could have a much more
direct effect in evading the adaptive immune
response. And this would be consistent with a resistance
directly against CD8 T-cells, as I just show you.
While for 1q gain, we see, perhaps a more direct with the
innate part of the immune system.
We also validated these findings in the context of single-cell
RNA seq data. In this
dataset, we pooled together about 90 patients from
published studies, and through different type of harmonization and
deconvolution, we were also able to confirm
that 1q gain is associated with a decreased level
of
T-cells and other immune cells, and 9p loss as well,
and macrophages as well for the 1q.
So the next question is, is 1q gain similar?
I showed you the study of 9p loss being associated with poor response
and poor survival in head and neck cancer, in other tumor sites as well.
What do we see for 1q gain? So for 1q gain,
again, we were fortunate to collaborate with Caris Therapeutics, and we
inferred the copy number alterations across
patients. In this case,
it's endometrial cancer. And this represents really a clinical need in the
context of this tumor type. Women with endometrial
cancer, especially with microsatellite unstable endometrial cancer, so
MSI, mismatch repair deficient colorectal cancer,
have received the frontline
immune checkpoint inhibitors such as pembrolizumab, and about only
50% of them respond. So there is a need to
really try to
really find
biomarkers. And so in this dataset, again, Caris Therapeutics,
about 300 patient and 1,000 patients for the non-ICB.
What we found was that 1q gain was predicted a poor immunotherapy
response in endometrial cancer, but not predictive in the context
of other therapies. Importantly, when we added
in a multivariate
Cox regression model, different parameters, including B-cell
tumor mutation burden, these are all MSI, so the mutation burden is
high everywhere, pretty much. CD8 T-cells,
PD-L1 IHC,
1q gain still retained significant in this multivariate
analysis, which to us was a very important
confirmation of the fact that this aneuploidy might be
an important biomarker.
In addition, we were also able to
see a similar effect in the context of melanoma.
In this case, there are multiple datasets that we were able to access, including
MSK dataset, as well as Caris Therapeutics here at the top.
And again, in this context as well, including in this
melanoma dataset, CD8 T-cell abundance, B-cell abundance,
TMB, tumor mutation burden, PD-L1 IHC, measure in
different ways by our colleagues at Caris Therapeutics,
where including those parameters in the model didn't sort of kill
the significance of the 1q gain.
Finally, in the last few slide, I wanted to show you
some similar
analysis that we performed this time, not in a human dataset,
but in a mouse, what I call sometimes a mouse mini-TCGA.
So in collaboration with Ben Stanger at UPenn,
we put together a
beautiful dataset of mouse
pancreatic adenocarcinoma tumors.
So what they did is that they took PDAC
tumors and derived single-cell derived tumors.
And then for each of these single cell, we performed, was a
collaboration, copy number alterations analysis by whole genome sequencing, as
well as analysis of the tumor microenvironment after each of these cell lines was
injected in immunocompetent mice.And so,
again, similar to the TCGA, also in this case, and of course in a much more
controlled manner, here the germline is the same.
The somatic is also the same in terms of mutation, it's KRAS p53.
We were able to associate the aneuploidy with
different features of the tumor microenvironment.
And I will just show you two vignettes that relates to our favorites, 9p loss and
1q gain.
So the first one is the association with the CD8 T-cells.
So we performed the same analysis in this mini mouse TCGA.
So the first plot
represents the association, in this case, r value, is simply
the r value between the copy number of each position in the mouse
genome and
the CD8 level in the microenvironment.
Here, this is the mouse genome, 20 chromosomes, and so each position
here is measured directly in the tumors as a
cytoband, as a region in the mouse genome.
However, in order to make the human mouse comparison easier, we
then perform a liftover from the mouse genome to the human genome.
So here you will see a plot that is over
23 chromosomes, so this is the human genome, where
the results of the mouse
analysis was liftover on the human genome.
And so
this analysis makes the comparison with the human
dataset possible in a very direct
way. And then finally, we also
measure the product between the r value of the mouse
dataset and the human dataset, and if they both go in the same direction, the r
value, the product, will be positive.
And as you can see here, it is a little small, but here on 9p, there is
a
peak
that is
positive and represents a negative association,
again, between the presence of 9p loss and the neutral event
in the context of CD8. So both in the mouse and the human dataset,
9p loss is associated with decreased CD8 T-cells.
We did a similar analysis now for macrophages.
So again, this is the correlation between the copy number alteration across the
mouse genome and the
amount of macrophages in the tumor microenvironment.
We then did a liftover of the mouse on the human
genome, and then a direct comparison between the mouse dataset,
the mini TCGA, and the human dataset.
And as you can see here, it's very clear 1q is the largest
chromosome arm in the human genome.
You can see clearly here there is a positive value when
we look at the r product between mouse and the human exactly at the
1q level. Suggesting that even in this
mouse
dataset, the 1q gain emerges as an
important
aneuploidy associated with a lower level of
macrophages
in the context of pancreatic cancer.
And this is the sort of box plots analysis for better
visualization. And so overall, I would just like to
mention these main three
take home message. The first one is that our lab and many other labs in
the field, as seen in recent years, that 9p
loss
is associated with immune evasion and poor immune checkpoint inhibitor response
across different tumor types, not all, mostly squamous tumors,
but also some others, including lung
adenocarcinoma. 1q gain,
I
also presented data suggesting that 1q gain is associated with immune evasion and
pure immunotherapy response across different tumor types.
These are a bit different tumor types.
They're not the squamous tumors, but tend to be the adenocarcinoma.
So,
lung adenocarcinoma, endometrial cancer, as well as
melanoma. And we are particularly interested here in the context of
endometrial cancer because of the clinical need of biomarkers in
microsatellite unstable endometrial
cancer patients. And finally, in our mouse cancer genomic
datasets, we were able to recapitulate the
association between 9p loss and 1q gain as a predictor of
decreased CD8 T-cells and decreased macrophages, respectively.
And so,
with that, I would just like to thank my lab,
especially Zi, Zi Chen, and Frank Liu, as well
as former member Lisa Katson,
and as well as Elaine, who performed much of the experimental
modeling of the 9p loss. And also collaborators, David Fenyo,
Mark Yarmakovich at NYU, Scott Lippman and Silvio Gutkind here at
UCSD, and Ben Stanger from UPenn, and several funders.
And thank you for sticking around.
Hi.
Yeah.
Thank you very much for your great talk.
I have a question regarding the endometrial cancer data.
And I was wondering if you look at the specific histotype with the
1q, whether it was any enrichment for high-grade serous
carcinoma, or it was for endometrioid, because
I was also puzzled by the fact that you haven't observed the same
associations for ovarian cancer.
Can you elaborate more on that?
Yes. This specific association is with endometrioid cancer,
which is I think also the main
histological subtype that is originally microsatellite unstable tumors.
The high grade tend to be on the microsatellite stable, more
aneuploid type of tumors. So mostly this
histological type.
Oh.
And sorry, in the context of ovarian cancer,
yeah, there is a slight association, but it's not super strong.
Ovarian cancer is one of the most chromosomally unstable and aneuploid genomes that
looks-Like this.
So it tends to be more unstable and near tetraploid and
probably not as
stable as other tumor types, such as oral or others.
But yeah.
Yeah. It's fascinating work.
I was trying to think about,
as you were describing this, I guess you could think about
the immune evasion functionally in a couple of ways.
One might be the aneuploidies
are kind of maybe altering
immune receptor expression, so MHC complex expression or
co-stimulator receptor interactions.
The other, I suppose, effect could be some of these cancers
are virally initiated, and so it
could be maybe that there's a clonal elimination, sort of
like a clonal antigen
effect. And
I'm just wondering about chromosome nine, whether you have any sense of whether
it's more likely to be an effect size that's compatible with, say,
regulation of MHC, or whether it could be something to do with
chromosome nine has antigens that might normally get strongly
eliminated by immune surveillance, but if the chromosome's deleted, then
it's sort of tolerizing the cell, and these
are hard questions.
Yeah. That's a great point, and reminds me about a lot of work from
Charlie Swanton and others, really showing this
clonal selection of loss of heterozygosity in specific regions
due to purifying selection of antigens or purifying selection
for
loss of MHC, for example, that would be on 6p.
HLA and MHC, that would be on 6p, which we do not see as so strong.
I don't know. We haven't performed that type of analysis looking at
antigens, specifically on 9p.
So I don't know. We haven't specifically asked that
question.
But
all I can say is that at least in our in vitro modeling,
the specific resistance to CD8 T-cells seems to be quite
reproducible, and that is independent of the
specific mutated antigen,
as far as we can tell. Yeah, actually it is, because it's just dependent on
CAR T-cell, if you wish, in vitro
engineered model.
Yeah, that's a great point to
think more about for the field.
Yeah.
Hi. Very nice talk.
Interesting story. It showed the arm-level gain and
loss related to outcome, and wondering if you have any
comment or had any chance to check other genomic features, like
a little imbalance at the 9p or 1q
gain or
bioallelic deletion or even whole genome
doubling?
Yeah. So
the allelic imbalance.
Of course, when you have gain or loss, you do have an allelic
imbalance.
We do not see a strong effect of copy number neutral
LOH, for example, in the context of
9p. So in the absence of copy, seems really
dependent on the copy number.
The-
Partial deletion, partial loss, copy neutral
im-
CNN LOH events. Yes. No, I understand.
The effect seems to be mainly driven by the loss of genomic material,
really. But we
cannot exclude that there could also be an effect due to the
CNN LOH. It's not the primary sort of genomic
event that stands out in the analysis.
The genome doubling, we take into account.
All of this is corrected for purity and ploidy.
The genome doublings, we do not use it as a covariate per se, but
we use the overall chromosomal instability, the overall aneuploidy score as
a proxy for that, if you wish.
And what was the last one? And yeah, these were the main two, right?
Yeah. So,
good point for the CNN LOH. I think there could be more there, but
although what we find, it's generally that is the loss of genomic material.
The other point is that here, this loss of 9p,
it's heterozygous.
And also, when we engineer the loss of 9p13 in these three
isogenic clones, it's heterozygous.
In fact, the homozygous loss of these regions, we contained about 20, 25 genes,
would be lethal for the cell. We predict it based on that map and
different essential genes. So I think only in
heterozygosity can survive. Of course, there
could be allelic imbalance, so it's possible that the maternal or paternal allele
that express more or less is differentially gained or lost, and
I think that's a good
question still.
Hi. I was very intrigued by the functional work that
you did to try and
map which region of 9p actually is responsible, and I'm curious if you've
done any single cell, or sorry, not single cell,
sort of single gene sort of screens to why did
you do this as opposed to just a random, a
9p-focused CRISPR screen, for example?
Right.
That was the same question.
It's one of the...
Yes, we are doing that at the same time.
If I had to guess, I think that it's not just a one gene thing, but it's
probably a cumulative effect. At least this has been shown, and
there is also in 1q in the case of NOTCH and perhaps MBM4 and others.
So we preferred to use the genome because we didn't have a gene resolution in
our predictive models, so we prefer to model what
happens in the patients. We have not done it, so I cannot tell you whether
just one gene would be sufficient, but
my prediction is that there will be more, but we are trying to narrow it
down to the specific gene.
Thank you.
Great. Wonderful.
Thank you everybody for the great
discussion and questions and talks. Thanks again to Sam and Nick. Thank you.